[Applaudissements]
excusez moi je travaillais chez foot
locker
il a voulu dire que c'était
instrumentalisé que dire quand ça n'est
pas vrai qu'une avance d'abord je
voudrais dire que ça n'est en aucun cas
un dérapage
ce sont des déclarations qui s'inscrit
dans une double continuité la première
continuité c'est le naufrage
intellectuelle et républicains de jean
luc mélenchon qui est devenu la
caricature de lui-même
jean luc mélenchon ça fait longtemps
qu'il est complètement indigne de la
fonction qu'il brigue
c'est le président de la république là
il en est devenu je vous dis à vous ce
que j'ai dit alexis corbière que les
canaris ne connais bien il est temps de
vous débarrasser du bout parce que vous
êtes une secte qui est prisonnier des
délires de cet homme qui les amis
devaient moore musée
il n'avait rien dit sur papa c'est au
café un appel au meurtre avant par les
domaines est bien là je vais parler de
ce que je veux c'est senna tu sais pas
mais moi la dictée moi je vais les
soutes simard-beaudry vous êtes-vous
l'émir et l'extrême droite voudrait des
services après vente et réseaux isolés
dans leurs douars les gens louent dijon
n'est pas l'heure d'une russie latine et
à vous buvez pas crédible j'aimerais que
l'adrénaline et d'isabelle lavigne et
cyril se retrouver dans un instant et il
sera avec moi des pendus il va être face
à l'actu on va voir son nouveau film
derniers mercenaires vous allez voir
c'est de la bombe atomique
jean claude van damme sera notre invité
gens connaissent
[Applaudissements]
besson
ce fonds
non vraiment je suis québécois russe et
je voyage beaucoup dans beaucoup de pays
et je vois beaucoup de gens et j'espère
que serra de mieux en mieux avec ce
vaccin mais donc il faut suivre ce qu'on
se contentera cela vous dit tout et a eu
peur pour tes parents quand même
énormément
ouais c'est ça ou alors porté par eva
serait ma mère sont en plus il ya le
sport c'est bien
encore une fois le ch l'ambiance qui
vient ces six et neuf mois intéressant
parce que finalement ils devraient être
au gouvernement jean claude van damme 1
finalement tu vois je le dirai jamais ce
qu'il a dit là non mais ce qu'il a dit
là c'est finalement l'essentiel de quoi
c'est quoi il vous a dit quoi il vous a
dit que le sport c'est essentiel pas de
bol on a fermé les salles de sport des
rebonds c'est dommage
[Applaudissements]
n était plus forte que la nôtre je crois
que la n1 la haine la haine ne sera pas
guéri avec la haine mais la haine se
guérit avec l'amour non mais ces
attentes en ça c'est important
on pense à moi je crois que la question
à poser c'est pourquoi tant de haine
vous avez un super t-shirt qu'est le web
c'est keith est menacé car on sait qui
c'est la merde ça change
[Applaudissements]
vous croyez vraiment que ça peut bien
faire là prévu la violence symbolique là
elle est terrible pour la société tout
entière pour les institutions pour le
pays voilà c'est pas et le fait qu'ils
n'étaient que giflé qu' il soit pas
blessé comme lui-même c'est le geste
voilà c mais ce geste lisant ce livre
c'est une transgression kiki terrible
encore une fois pour la société parce
que ça s'explique la s'explique par le
phénomène de violence que nous
subissions depuis pas mal d'années en
tout cas en france et plus précisément
depuis deux ans je peux comprendre à un
moment donné du moins entendre
l'exaspération de certaines personnes et
qui en viennent à des gestes violents
aujourd'hui j'entends monsieur guaino
sur la symbolique du président de la
république je l'entends moi j'ai plus
l'impression que c'est l'homme qui se
fait gifler et non pas le président de
la république je ne vais pas faire ma
chronique vous troubler la regardes et
tu vas me dire tu reconnais quelqu'un
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est quoi ce bordel
encore mais pousse à charcé maman bon
avec serré l'on a fait une belle
rigolade
alors tu sais à quel point je vais faire
l'émission tous les soirs et je te
remercie à quel point tu me défends
aussi tous les soirs concernant le sujet
de guillaume genton mais je suis et je
reste quand même une grande fille je
sais me défendre
après il faut savoir que guillaume reste
quand même un beau garçon même si un
style à revoir ça reste quand même un
beau garçon en tous les cas je vous fais
tous un gros bisou à toute l'équipe à
cyril à toute l'école tous les
chroniqueurs et bien sûr à guillaume à
très bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après
[Applaudissements]
allah
c'est ma personnalité française préférée
c'est la personne voilà je te dis que je
pense que tu les aimes aussi regardent
il est là il est avec nous christian
clavier
[Applaudissements]
il doit y avoir un décalage christian
tentant magnifiquement et tu es
tellement beau fernando c'est simple et
tellement beaux arts mais merci merci
mais tout aussi jolie fille moi je
voulais vous faire un petit coucou parce
que j'ai pas pu venir
ça fait très longtemps que je ne suis
pas inquiet je sais que tu m'as manqué
tu sais rien des premiers vaccinés
tu te sens bien mais bien sûr je te sens
tu as peur ouais ouais pas peur c'est le
seul moyen pour qu'on se retrouve les 1
c'est à dire oui mais oui mais tout ça
et ces écoutes ces faits moi j'ai
discuté que m me m'ont dit tu crois
peut-être la trappe et moins tu
développeras pas quelque chose de grave
voilà donc moi je fais ce qu'il veut
c'est la liberté de chacun
moi j'ai fait je trouve ça très bien
parce que ça me permet de me frotter à
mes amis encore de tous les gens qui
sont mais sérieux gens qui nous explique
qu'on est en dictature a d'abord ces
rames dans les dictatures on puisse
expliquer qu'on est en dictature
et puis franchement tous les mecs qui
explique qu'on est en dictature avec le
pass sanitaire je propose qu'on les
envoie en stage 15 jours à cuba ou en
corée du nord qui voit ce que c'est une
vraie dictature quand on joue contre
louvre on est au gnouf pendant cinq ans
je pense que les gens devraient un tout
petit peu avant de parler de dictature
sanitaire aller voir ce que c'est qu'une
vrai dire des séries rotarienne là bas
alors ce qu'on pense des spectateurs
s'est pris 8 71
visière et non à 29,200 merci à yanis et
ziadi merci à tricia trek excusez moi
allez regarder où on avance on a fait un
dossier allait regarder raison que je
suis dit c'est mon frère qui vient nous
à part
[Applaudissements]
journalier
ici on parle pas comme ça des taureaux
suffit qu'on respecte les forêts dans
l'électorat gilles respecter les
habitués qui respecte les nouveaux noms
m'attendait dans le respect qu'ils
rejoignent et je respecte ou non mais je
m'excuse du comportement peut-être
discourtois mais franchement arrêtez
d'écrire des arènes romaines et gilou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
mais s'il n'y a pas mieux restant fière
choix c'est peut-être parce qu'elle
avait envie de vous voir ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu fais la liste robert sajaloli de même
annoncé au prix je veux pas seulement
c'est la maman de ses lames of de
guillaume deunf penser qu'on peut aller
ensemble véritablement moi je trouve
magnifique
abbas est gentil et guillaume genton
retrouve vous êtes le soleil caroline il
peut être votre parasol est ce que
serait peut être votre style absolument
pas vous êtes une caricature et c'est
précisément ce que j'essayais de passer
est une girouette la girouette du paf
vous avez évolué en fonction des
événements là où était votre intérêt à
retourner faire du kathak du canasson et
foutez nous la paix mon propos est
exactement là c'est à dire que
l'insultent c'est toujours l'argument du
pauvre pierre mathieu vous devriez en
faire du canasson comme vous dites ça
vous apprendrai plein de choses mais
tellement chose parce qu'à cheval
figurez vous il faut le calme du moine
l'autorité du maître est la bienvenue
ensuite j'ai un autre projet artistique
d'un autre projet artistique
oh oui merci déjà notre projet
artistique est un disque que je vais
enregistrer chez universal il faut
savoir que léo ferré a été mon maître et
mon ami pendant 15 ans et plus avant de
mourir il avait projeté d'enregistrer un
album et que cet album il n'a pas pu
l'enregistrer parce qu'il est mort
[Rires]
brive c'est pas moi c'est plus que ça et
vous remerciez pas c'est la convention
merci frontaliers français ça c'est une
consistance il remercie le jury
malheureusement c'est la fin des
missions mais juste j'aimerais parce que
vous avez été vous avez marqué ses
missions cette année sylvie et gilles et
vous remercier parce qu'ils font mention
merci frontaliers français ça si francis
francis merci d'avoir c'est la fin des
missions mais juste j'aimerais parce que
vous avez été vous avez marqué ses
missions cette année sylvie airs il est
ce que vous pouvez juste chanter tous
les deux pour cette fin de l'émission
carrément édition love me tender love
mitch ou aux téléspectateurs pour cette
dernière c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
mais avec tout
des canards